- [Steph Gooch] The AWS
cost and usage report,
one of the most powerful data sets we have
to understand our cloud footprint.
It was actually released 11 years ago
and can you believe what it
was like before that existed?
And we've come so far.
We have a Athena
integration, we have CUR 2.0,
we have Focus, we have
the CUR Query Library.
We have grown so much since then.
However, some of the
challenges customers have
still are the same from 11 years ago.
That is why we've broken down
our session into three topics.
Optimization.
Who doesn't wanna save money in the cloud?
This is a classic reason why we have
the cost and use report to be able to find
where we're spending money and to save it.
But it can be quite nuanced
where those opportunities are
and they can even be improved
by having other data sets.
Cost allocation.
One of the biggest conversations
I have with customers every single day
is about being able to understand
and see your spend.
Securing our costs.
Not something we typically
discuss in the world of FinOps
and optimization,
but we hopefully all in this room
enjoy using the cost and use report
and we wanna allow others to do that,
but we wanna be able
to control the access,
so that they can't see
data they shouldn't.
In today's session, we
are gonna cover these
and give you new ways to access
your cost and usage report
and solve these problems.
Just to introduce myself,
my name is Steph Gooch,
I'm a senior SA advocate at
AWS and joining me as Andy.
- [Andy Brown] Hi
everyone, I'm Andy Brown.
I'm a senior manager
specializing in FinOps.
- [Steph Gooch] Before
we get into the coding
and querying of today's session,
we wanted to warm up with a little game.
It's early, I know,
but we thought we'd
get the energy flowing.
So if I can get everyone
to stand up if you can
and would like to participate.
The way this game is gonna work,
is gonna be a question on the screen
and you're gonna have two options.
If you think it's the first answer,
you'll put your left hand up.
If you think it's the second answer,
you'll put your right hand up.
It's an honesty, Gabe, if you
get it wrong, you sit down.
There's only four questions, okay?
The last one standing will get
a very special CUR related sticker.
At the end of the session,
you can come and claim.
The idea is to just
recap on some CUR basics
and make sure everyone's
on the same level.
First question, what version
of the AWS cost and usage
report has the newest features?
CUR Legacy
or CUR 2.0?
Three, two, one.
CUR 2.0.
Did anyone get that wrong?
Well done folks. Well done. Well done.
Okay, so this is the newest CUR.
This is one that has all the features.
If you have not used it, you
need to start deploying it
and this is what we'll be
using in today's session.
- [Andy Brown] Where is the
data for the CUR stored?
Is it S3 or RDS?
Three, two, one.
Yes. S3 is the right answer.
Basically any data you can get into S3
is available for you to
be able to query in Athena
and that's what we're gonna be showing you
as well later today.
- [Steph Gooch] Okay, you're
all doing really well.
I need to have a lot of stickers.
Are tags automatically
added to the CUR by default?
Yes? No?
Three, two, one.
Get those hands up. No.
Okay, that's got a few of you.
The key phrase there is by default
tags you have to have cost
allocation tags enabled
so you don't have all your
organizations, hundreds of tags.
We'll show some tagging there.
You can be very smug if
you've got that one right.
I can feel people's energy.
All right, last query.
- [Andy Brown] Can you add
account names into CUR 2.0?
Yes or no?
Three, two, one.
Yes.
- [Steph Gooch] Giving it
away at the front. Yes.
- [Andy Brown] Yes.
This is one of the new
features available in CUR 2.0
for you doing it
and we're gonna be using
that as one of our ways
of securing the curve further.
- [Steph Gooch] Brilliant.
All right you guys, go get a sticker.
Please sit down and come to us at the end
and you can grab one of
our CUR special stickers.
That was a little bit of fun.
Get everyone standing and
moving before our session,
'cause we know it is nice and early
and thanks again for joining us.
Let's get coding.
So this is a live coding session.
Like I said, we'll be querying,
it is live so we'll be doing it
and we'll wanna have some help.
So we'll be asking questions to you guys,
that's the interactive part
and you can shout them out.
If you have questions about the session,
we'll be taking those outside at the end,
so we can get through everything today.
But warning, I am dyslexic.
There will be spelling
errors, there might be errors.
What we have done is we have
a nice little tally over here.
So in our sections, whoever
gets the most errors
will have to do some kind
of forfeit at re:Invent.
We do this every year.
Make sure that you get
our LinkedIns at the end
to see who have what we do
at the end of our session.
We will make sure to share a GitHub repo
in our resources at the end
that have all of our queries
so you can take them home,
so don't feel that you have to make
any kind of specific notes.
We've also re-prerecorded a session
that's gonna be on a YouTube channel
so you can watch this back
later and follow along.
But with that I'm gonna hand over to Andy
for our first query.
- [Andy Brown] Great, thank you Steph.
So who's been in this situation before?
You're at your desk doing your day job
and you get an email from AWS.
Your custom normally detection detected,
your NAT Gateway bend has increased.
So you decide to go
into AWS cost explorer,
you filter by the service EC2 other
and you see yes,
not only has your NAT Gateway
spend started to increase,
we're also seeing some NAT Gateway bytes
and we are also seeing some
data transfer reasonable bytes.
So audience shout out if you know
what data transfer regional bytes are.
- [Steph Gooch] Into AZ.
- [Andy Brown] I think
I heard an into AZ. Yes.
So data transfer of regional bytes,
it's inavailability zone data transfer.
So for example, an EC2
instance in USD one A,
talking to an US EC2
instance in US D one B.
And to be honest,
I don't really remember
all the different types
of data transfer and how
they pair US usage types
and costs flow and occur.
And so when I saw this,
I should typed into Amazon queue
and it told me.
But Steph, if you saw this
and you got this email,
what would you do?
- [Steph Gooch] I would just
push it to the developers
and run away probably,
which is what you're meant to do, right?
- [Andy Brown] Yeah, one approach
but probably not the AWS recommended way.
So what I'm gonna be showing you today is,
I'm gonna be going into
the cost and usage report.
We're gonna filter and
have a look at the costs,
but then we'll realize that
we need more information.
So we're gonna be
integrating a new data source
and then hopefully we'll
find that root cause
and optimize this spend.
So with that, let's go into the console.
Cool, here we go.
So everything we're doing
today, we're doing in CUR 2.0
and we already have it
set up to go into Athena.
I have this query to begin with
which is their designed to mimic
what we're seeing in cost explorers.
So let me run this.
It's gonna start coming back with
the usage types coming through,
you'll see we've got a variety
of different NAT Gateways
and we've got the spend,
but from this view it's
still not very clear on
what is causing that increase
we saw in Cost Explorer.
And so the first thing
we're gonna be doing,
is we're gonna be creating
like a quasi pivot table.
I'm gonna take the
September and October costs
and split them out into
their own separate columns.
So lemme scroll up,
I'm gonna just navigate
this outta the way,
so make it bigger.
So within the sum statement
I'm gonna be putting a case,
think about cases being an else statement.
So case when billing period equals
and we'll do September 1st,
then return the cost, else return nothing.
So when this runs
only September cost will
start appearing this.
And then so I can rename
the column September
and then I just need to do
exactly the same for October,
so let me copy, put in the comma,
I'm gonna change this to 10 for October
and change it to October. Cool.
Now I can change my select statement.
So no longer the billing period
because I have my worst
statement to narrow it down
to only September and October.
I have it split out into
two separate columns,
so I can delete that.
I'm also gonna delete usage type.
Right now I don't care
if it's data transfer
or NAT Gateway related,
I just want to know which
resources are causing this spike
to work out, what's to do next.
So let me delete that.
I can change my group bys.
'cause we're now in grouping one,
one resource which is the resource ID.
And I'm gonna change my order by,
'cause I want to see
what's the most expensive
resources in December,
'cause that's where in October,
'cause that's where we're
seeing the increase.
So fingers crossed everything right,
so let me run this now.
- [Steph Gooch] While that's running.
If you do see us about to make an error,
you can shout out and stop us.
'Cause often it's easier if people
when you're looking at
someone else's query
to find an error.
So feel free to shout out
if you see us about to make an error.
- [Andy Brown] And my
common one is commas.
I always forget about the commas
or add too many commas.
So as we see here,
we've got some NAT Gateway
spends coming through
and we've got some new
spends happening in October.
So we've got this one here,
it's pretty much same,
so this must have been
around the environment before
but we've got two new resources.
I could have tagging on this NAT Gateway
which will probably tell me who owns this
or what part of application with it.
But the issue we have with NAT Gateway
and also with the mail
of data transfer is,
we don't know why.
Like for those who don't
know what NAT Gateway is,
there's something you deploy
within normally private VPCs
which will allow your resources
to have secure access out to the internet.
It's just the middleman in the process.
It doesn't actually
generate information itself.
So in this situation,
am I reaching out to the application team,
'cause maybe they changed
the application deployment
and something's changed.
Or am I reaching out
to the networking team?
'Cause maybe they changed
something in the configuration
which is causing these
two NAT Gateways spin up
and the data transfer going through.
And this is where we hit the limitations
of the cost continuity report
and we have to try and
work out what's next.
I am 100% not a networking
specialist. Really I'm not.
And so as always I use
Q, Q is our best friend.
As if I open up the panel here,
hopefully it'll show you
the query we ran earlier.
Here we go.
And what I did was Q
helped me cost optimize
my NAT Gateways and
the things it tells me,
it tells me exactly some of the reasons
and why that gateway spend
might be going across.
And then it also tells me
like where do you want to go
for extra information.
Here Q is recommending
that we use VPC Flow Logs.
So VPC Flow Logs is something you enable
in each of your VPCs
and what it does is it
tracks all the data flows
within your resources,
so you can work out what's going on
and who's talking to who.
When you deploy it,
data starts appearing within minutes.
So it's not something like the CUR,
you have to wait for maybe up to 24 hours
for the data to start flowing through.
And also you get two choices
of information of where it can go out to.
It can either go to CloudWatch,
so it's with the rest
of your application logs
or you can actually have
the data flow into S3.
If you choose S3,
VPC Flow Logs also give you
a cloud formation template
and the cloud formation template
will do the full Athena setup for you.
And so we enable VPC
Flow Logs in our area,
we ran that cloud formation template
and this is what we have set
up within our Athena today.
So they expand out the database
on the left hand side again,
I can change now
as you see I've got my VPC
Flow Logs analysis table
and I have the table here.
Whenever I get a new data source,
I normally span them out
and I start having a little
bit of a nosy around,
'cause I want to get my feel of the data
before I start using it.
So let me preview and let me hide Q,
don't need them anymore.
Okay, and so as the data
cuts are coming back,
we'll start getting some of
the information available
in VPC Flow Logs.
We have the account ID all sitting in.
We have the source and
destination address,
we then have some port information
and then we have some byte information.
So for example, this row
here is representing 44 bytes
of information going
between the two resources.
We have the start and end time.
This is all in unix epoch time.
And so if you wanted to translate this out
into something a little bit machinery,
there is a function within
Athena to do that for you.
But in our case we just,
the daily granularity is enough
and the VPC Flow Logs is
automatically partitioned by day
and so I don't need to
worry about converting this.
So let me change this into
something a little bit more
just the columns of information I want.
So I want the source address
and the destination address
and then I'm gonna do a sum of the bytes.
Can I type today? There we go.
Sum off bytes.
Oh, I'm gonna add, I need to
add in some filters now here.
So I need her do aware statement,
'cause I'm gonna do where
the month is in September.
October, so she just narrow it down
to the months where we saw
that's increase in spike.
I need to add in a group by one and two
for my source and destination address.
I am also gonna order by
the who's talking the most.
So I'm gonna add in my order by
and I'm gonna order by free descending,
'cause I want to have
those biggest speakers.
And then keep the limit 10,
'cause there's a lot of
resources in my account.
I actually want to know
who are the biggest ones
to work out what's going on.
I could just run this right now
and this will return some information,
but the byte numbers are
gonna be really large,
'cause we've got a lot
of transfer going in.
And so really, what I want to do is,
I want to convert the bytes to gigabytes
because that's how AWS
charges for us stuff.
So we can align it to
what's happening in the CUR.
And so audience shout
out if you know this,
if I take bytes and I divide
it by 1,024, what do I get?
Yeah, I hear some kilobytes.
And another thousand 24? Megabytes.
And then the final 1,024? Gigabytes. Yeah.
So I'm doing that,
so I can then compare it
to my costing user report.
So let me run this
and fingers crossed we'll
get some information back.
Here we go.
Okay, we'll get information back.
But all the numbers are
returning zero bytes
and this is due to the
way Athena handles data.
So if we look at the definition
of the table here on the left-hand side,
you'll see that bytes are
stored as a big integer.
And so this is the number
without any decimal places.
And so at the above when divided by 1,024,
Athena continues to ignore decimal places.
So you remember that row
where we had that 44 bytes of transfer.
You drive that by 1,024,
you're gonna get zero
if you round it down.
And so there is a way to force Athena
to think about those bytes
and include them within it.
And the easiest way to do this
is should put a 0.0 at each
of the end of these numbers.
'Cause we're gonna say divide everything,
but I care about the decimal places.
So now when I run this, fingers crossed,
I'm gonna get some real data
coming back and here we go.
We've got the top four
rows coming through.
They're the biggest ones.
Everything else is under
like one gigabytes,
so they're small in the
whole scheme of things.
But like anyone know these
IP addresses, like no like,
like if you do know IP addresses
at the top of your head,
then well done.
But I don't know these IP addresses,
they don't really mean anything for me.
And so once again
we're back to our favorite friend Q.
And so this tab here
represents the account
where the issue's happening.
This is where we deployed our VPC
and I've gone ahead and asked Q
to explain one of the IP addresses
and you see it's come,
it's able to pick up
exactly which instance ID,
it's got the service, we stopped it,
it tells me what instance type
and all the relevant information.
And so what we actually did was,
I chucked all these IP addresses into Q
and told me to tell me what they are
and also group them together.
We have a quite large environment,
we've got auto scaling up and down,
and this, which one is it?
Here we go. Here we go.
And this is what Q returned.
It's using a light statement,
'cause like I mentioned we've
got auto scaling groups.
So the IP addresses of the
instances are changing over time
and this categorized it
into all the different subnets we have.
We then have the two NAT Gateways.
We've got running environment,
both their public and
their private IP addresses.
And then we have just general group by.
When I ask Q about some
of the IP addresses,
it just didn't recognize them.
It couldn't find them
within our environment.
And so it made a guess.
The guess was either
it's like an internet,
maybe there's a file we're
downloading or getting from,
or maybe it's an AWS
service, maybe it's S3
or RDS or something like that,
it's reaching out too.
And another situation,
'cause we just can what we can control,
which you're gonna group it under here
and then this repeated again
for the destination location.
So let me take this,
I'm gonna copy you and let
me go back to my query.
Here we go.
And so I'm gonna just replace source
and destination address
with those two queries.
So now when I run it,
fingers crossed we'll
get a little bit more
useful information.
Here we go. And it started to categorize.
So I have a challenge for you.
Can anyone recognize which
row number is the issue?
Oh, did I hear?
So three.
- Someone said four.
- [Andy Brown] A four, no three,
I'm pretty sure three.
Yes, three is the issue.
There's two reasons why I know this.
One, I ask you,
but two, and I'll show you in a moment.
I went back to what our
fundamentals in the cost are.
But I'll tell you why this is an issue
because we're not networking.
This is not a networking session.
This is advanced analytics
would occur. Two reasons.
First of all, I mentioned
that NAT Gateways
are designed to provide private resources
access to the internet.
We have a public subnet
using this NAT Gateway
and a public resource already
has a public IP address.
It doesn't need to go NAT Gateway,
it can just go to the internet itself.
And so why it's rooting that.
The second issue,
we have this public subnet
in availability zone two
talking to a NAT Gateway
in availability zone one
and that's causing that
inter AZ data transfer.
So like I said,
that was purposely
designed to challenge you.
I wasn't expecting people
to be able to identify this.
And so how do we actually
identify what the issue is
and go with and it's down to the cost,
it's all about the money at the end.
And so what I'm gonna do next,
is I'm gonna work out what the NAT Gateway
and data transfer charges are
for these entries within this table.
I'm gonna be starting with
using a with statement.
So W statement is where you
create a subquery win Athena.
So we're saying run everything here
and we're gonna use it again later.
So I'm gonna do with,
I'm gonna call it VPC
as open the bracket
and then go all the way
to the end of the crew
we were working before,
I want to take the semicolon
away and close the bracket.
So that whole thing we've
been playing around with
is now called VPC.
So I can do select star from VPC
and now I'm gonna add in my two columns
for NAT Gateway and data transfer charge.
I'm gonna use my old friend case,
say case when source location is like NAT
or destination locations like Nat.
So anything which is using a NAT Gateway,
then I'm gonna take the
sum with the gigabytes
and I'm gonna to it by 0.045.
The reason for 0.045
is this is how much AWS charges
for that gateway way data
processing within USD1 one A.
Q told me this when in my earlier query.
So that's how I get it from.
I'm gonna then everything
else will be zero
and call this as NAT data USD.
Next statement is then
for the enter a valid
C zone data transfer.
So this is gonna be case where
and the source location is like AZ1
and we want an and statement
because we want it where AZ1
is talking to availability zone two.
So destination location is like AZ2,
then this is gonna be the sum of gigabytes
and this time we're gonna
be times it by 0.02,
'cause that's how much we charge for into
availability zone data transfer.
And then I need the
same again for this one.
So let me copy this,
put this and we're gonna do the other way.
So we've got availability zone two,
talking of two availability
zone one and then L zero.
And then this can be then
my data transfer USD.
Fingers crossed, this is all good.
Let me run this.
It's running or is a
good sign. Here we go.
And as you can see,
it is row free, all the charges.
Remember if you go back to that
original cost explorer view,
the NAT Gateway data
processing started up,
the data transfer started up
and we can see it's all row free.
What this tells me now is I can reach out
to my networking team to investigate.
We got maybe a configuration change.
Maybe they did something
for the root tables
for that public subnet,
which is now forcing,
it goes in that gateway
and it's just that extra information
to go to them to provide it.
And so what I want you to
take away from this is,
think about what other data sources.
I do love the CUR.
I wouldn't be on this stage
if I didn't love the CUR,
but it's not the answer for everything.
Maybe it is data transfer investigating
and that's where the VPC
Flow Logs come through.
Or maybe you're investigating
extended support charges
and why they started introduced
and you want to bring
in an inventory report.
As long as you can get it into
S3, you can get to Athena.
Finally, if you don't know what to do,
use Amazon Q.
The example I'm showing you today
is a genuine customer
problem I helped with
and I really had no clue what to do.
I use Q for everything.
I chucked all the information,
all the results into Q
and it told me exactly what to do.
It told me where to send
people who to go look into,
'cause Q knows your AWS account.
Everything I showed you today
is from the free tier of Q as well.
So it didn't cost me anything to run it.
So this part of this session
was very much focusing
on a particular service.
We're looking at NAT Gateway.
But what happens if you wanted to work out
if your whole application
is running efficiently
and if you have the
right KPIs to track that.
With that I'm gonna hand it over to Steph
to talk a little about our
favorite friend Mr. AI.
- [Steph Gooch] Thanks Andy. Yes.
Cost allocation, like I said earlier,
one of the big challenges
we see with customers,
which has been made trickier
by things like Amazon Bedrock
when it comes to allocating that spend.
So we are gonna focus on just diving into
some cost allocation for Bedrock usage
and then looking at a bigger picture.
But there are two big
reasons why we see customers
not being able to cost
allocate Bedrock accurately.
The first is billing entities.
So when you choose your models,
these have an effect on the entities
and these show up differently
in the cost and usage report.
So our first party models,
these are ones that are trained,
sold, and developed by AWS.
So think of things like Nova and Titan.
Next we have second party models.
These are ones that are developed
and trained by someone else,
but they're sold on AWS.
Think of things like Llama.
Finally we have third party models.
These are ones developed,
trained and sold by someone else,
but to get them onto AWS,
you need to use marketplace.
This is why they show
up slightly differently
and it can't be as simple
as select or wear Bedrock.
The second challenge we have
is when you use a model,
the resource ID just shows
up as the model name.
That's all the information you get
when you do it by default.
So it's unlike an EC2
or like we saw with the NAT Gateways
where you get a specific ID
that you can go and find in your accounts.
You can't find it, it's just a model.
But there is a way around that
and that is inference profiles.
Inference profiles are
a way to pre-configure
how you interact with Bedrock
and they allow you to
choose some customization.
So what model do you want to use?
What temperature do you wanna have?
And you can tag it,
of course tags are gonna come up.
So you can tag this resource
and then see who is using that model
and where are they using it.
You can do this in things
like CloudFormation.
This is an example I have
and this is also in the GitHub
repo we'll share at the end.
And so you can reuse
this in your applications
or you can use it in an SDK,
this is Python and you can have that.
What we'll be doing is,
we will be cost allocating some usage
based on the department tag,
you can see on there,
to see who is spending
money from what department
in our accounts.
Let's get into it.
So I already have a bit
of a pre-done query.
So it has some simple stuff in it,
things like product name,
usage, spend, resource,
classic information you use.
But I wanna draw your attention down here
to the where statement.
This is where we cover
those first, second,
third party model information.
So where we have product code like Bedrock
or product, product name like Bedrock,
that is how we cover everything.
For example, when you use Claude,
it comes up with Claude
brackets, Amazon Bedrock.
So we just wanna check that one line.
The same with things like tokens,
when it comes to one and two P parties,
you have line item usage
type like token, lowercase,
but you also have line item
usage type like token uppercase.
Notice, no there's no S
because sometimes it's
token, sometimes it's tokens.
Don't know why I didn't make it.
But we wanna cover everything,
so we've just got these
where statements in there.
I've already run this query
and we can start to see some of the usage.
So we see our spend, yeah, yeah,
but this is where we
start to see information
like that resource ID.
So I wanna show you an example.
These two rows are what it looks like
when you have no inference profile,
you just have usage of a model, right?
If you wanted to cost allocate
this, it's a bit useless.
So we can see some people
are starting to use inference
profiles and see some tags.
So we see things like the dev teams,
they're using things like Nova Micro,
we have security teams using Pro
and we even have some sales
teams who are using Claude.
So we can see this difference
from that first line,
but we can see who the tags are.
What we're gonna do first is,
we can see like here
some people haven't tagged
their spend, naughty people.
We wanna make sure that we
can go and find those people
and say, hey guys, you've already
got the inference profile,
you've already done the work.
Let's just tag it. Let's
add those couple of lines.
So we're gonna do a query
just to find those people
to have a bit of a hit list.
So we're also gonna use a with statement,
tokens as bracket everything up
and select from tokens.
All right, so what
information do we need to get?
Well we're probably gonna
wanna grab those resource IDs
so we can see what account
and what the inference profile hash is.
Then we're gonna get some usage
because we wanna know who are
the heavy hitters for this.
We don't just want people
who are doing hardly any work
and like POCs,
we want some bigger maybe
production workloads.
So we'll give that a name
and then we'll also get our spend.
'Cause as Andy said, it all
comes back to the money.
Because we have spend, we
have to have some group bys.
So group by one in this case
and we'll do a where filter.
So the where filter is gonna be,
where the resource ID
is like if we look down here,
we can see this application
inference profile.
That's the kind of calling
card that we're using one.
So we can drop that in there
and I don't want ones
that are already tagged
so we can just filter those out.
So where my user department tag
that I've extracted is null.
Oh god, no. Guys, Andy go put tally up.
- [Andy Brown] We got the first one.
- [Steph Gooch] What have I done wrong?
Oh, what is it?
No, it's just like, isn't it?
Well there had to be some
drama in the session.
You could say I planned that.
Okay, so here we have
my inference profiles,
a nice little list that we can go and say,
hey, you teams, you're in this account,
we can see some usage.
Can you just go and tag this resource?
Because we need to be able
to cost allocate our
applications relevantly,
but we wanna cost allocate
the ones that have tagged it.
So a small change we need to do for this
is we need changes to is not null,
get rid of the application,
'cause it's kind of mute because of that.
And rather than resource ID,
we can use user department.
What will now see is our user departments,
there's some usage and
some unblended spend.
It's as simple as that,
we've got some cost allocation.
But one thing I wanna
draw your attention to,
is the usage amount.
So what we can see is the sales teams,
they're the big spenders that
we have in our organization.
They have oh, $2,
but we look at things like the dev team
and they have a third of the spend
but almost the same usage.
Does anyone know why that is?
Almost someone said free to.
It's because of the model selection.
So earlier you saw the dev teams
and the security teams,
they're using Amazon Nova,
which is a fraction of the
cost of things like Claude.
Maybe the sales team need to use Claude
for whatever they're doing.
But if you are also looking to
optimize your Bedrock spend,
having some decisions about
what models you're using
will impact your cost.
So if you start to see a team,
a project department spend really spike
because they're using Bedrock,
you could go and have a
conversation with this data
and say, hey, your model
selection is really impacting it.
Is that the right model?
If it is, fine, if not,
maybe POCs developing,
try some cheaper models
like the Amazon native ones.
With that,
what happens when Bedrock
is part of a wider project?
So not just specific to its
own little tokens in and out.
What if we wanna think bigger?
What if it's part of a full story?
And what if we wanna
track optimization work?
See if we have moved to a cheaper model
or if we delete things
like idle NAT Gateways
that we don't need are incorrectly set up.
This is where something
like unit cost comes in.
So the unit cost is the
expenditure to sell one unit
of something or one click.
And the story in this image is,
someone's cost is going up.
Like we just talked about, the
spend is growing and growing,
the project we hope is doing well.
And the question is,
is the spend going up
because more people are
using our application,
more people are kind of logging in,
more people are demanding
information from our applications.
Or is it because someone
left something running,
like a NAT Gateway or someone
chose an expensive model?
How do we work that out?
And that is where unit cost comes in.
So we take the cost and divide it by
things like invocations or
usage of an application.
What I've done is,
I've made us a little application
that we're gonna show just
a simple little web app
which covers which using
resources like EC2,
Aurora, Lambda, Bedrock.
And the question is how much
does that one click cost?
That is the question we wanna answer.
So what we need to do to do that is,
we need to grab all of
the spend of our usage
and then divide it by some kind of unit,
some kind of invocation.
And we can do that
because the driving force
for this Bedrock usage is Lambda.
So every time I click that button,
a Lambda function gets triggered
and we can actually grab
that data from the CUR.
So that can be our usage amount
and then divide it by the cost.
This is something that I didn't know
before we got into the session
and we started playing around with ideas
that you can actually extract this
from the cost and use report,
so we are gonna do that now.
Does anyone know how I
grab the usage of Lambda
in the cost and usage report?
What column it is?
No, that's okay. It's usage.
Unsurprisingly it's actually usage amount.
We can actually steal this
from my previous query.
So usage amount, if we drop
that in here, and we summit,
and I filtered based on Lambda,
we filter based on the application
and the account ID and the month.
If we drop that in there,
we'll start to see how many times
that Lambda function was hit.
How many times in a couple of months
people have hit that button.
Great. Now we have a base,
now we need to go and get some spend,
so we can group that up.
This invocations as.
So we're just gonna grab
our spend for this part,
for this specific application.
So we'll grab it from the CUR.
So all we're gonna need
is are some of our spend.
We can grab that from
there, from our other query.
Always safer to copy and paste as cost.
We're also gonna see what
products we have in here.
We wanna make sure that we're capturing
all the right information.
And finally we need billing period,
'cause we wanna check
when we're doing this,
we're just looking over a
certain couple of months.
'Cause we have a group
by, we gotta do that sum.
So some we have group by,
group by one into three
and we need a where statement.
Luckily I've done a great job
of tagging in this application
and so we've got a little tag we can use.
So our tag,
oh, it's 'cause we're
on the wrong data set.
If you ever have across that situation
where suddenly you can't
auto create information,
it's because it's not on the right table.
So, you know, my one is called
oh, one brackets,
it's a user and it's my FinOps tag
equals nice AI app.
Very simple. Just
selecting a spend for this.
Oh, tell me.
(audience member speaking softly)
(gasp) You get an extra special
sticker because he saved me.
That's what friends do.
We're not friends apparently.
All right group by
and it is, oh we also need
another where statement.
So we're just grabbing this month's thing.
Am I safe?
- [Andy Brown] No.
- [Steph Gooch] Group
by one and three, right?
You can put tally on.
- [Andy Brown] I think I know
who's gonna be doing
the challenge. (laughs)
- [Audience member] The
catch is like a negative.
- [Steph Gooch] Yeah, it's been more fun.
You guys can see how we can fix errors.
It's a more interesting show.
So now we can see the resources we have
and the cost as well.
What is interesting is,
some of these are gonna be quite static.
So for the September, my resource
wasn't on the whole time,
but if it was on 24/7, the same amount,
it's gonna be very similar in cost.
Things like Bedrock really differentiate
because of how many
tokens come in and out.
When I run that little web app,
sometimes it gives me a massive amount,
sometimes it gives me a small
amount of information back.
Those things shift.
So those costs are quite variable.
So now we have all of this information,
we can do another one with
spend, grab all of this.
I don't need my product
kind of breakout anymore
so I can get rid of that.
Change that to two.
And now we're gonna combine this data.
So we're gonna collect select from spend
and we're gonna do it in a join
to connect these two things together,
in a join invocations,
we're gonna make a little shorthand
to make the combination of
these a little bit easier
and we're gonna select the information.
So select,
star S dot cost.
We're gonna do I dot total invocations
and then the very simple
arithmetic of the first one
divided by the second one.
We're also gonna grab that billing period
because this is how
we're gonna join these.
So we're gonna join on
I dot billing period
equals S dot billing period.
Any issues? Am I safe?
- Oh, no.
- Oh, every time.
Guys, I thought we were
friends, where's the support?
Now we can see these things.
Oh I've gotta do a forfeit.
Now we can see our cost per click.
So we have those 89 clicks.
We have similar numbers
because they were about the
similar amount of spend,
similar things.
Okay, so what?
What if we optimize?
What if we got rid of vital
resources we don't need?
Or what if we change model?
What if we move to graviton?
What if we right-sized?
What's gonna happen to
that per click cost?
So what we can do is,
we're gonna add in another
month's worth of spend
where I actually went and did my row,
I went and optimized
and now we'll see hopefully
that the spend per click has dropped down.
So it's now, what's that?
A quarter of the cost by optimizing.
What I hopefully wanna
inspire you with this
is to show you how to get this data, yes.
But if you are doing optimization work
in your organizations,
try and find some KPI you can do.
You can also do things
like compute gigabytes
or you can do any kind
of usage you can gather.
People often try and
focus on grabbing data
that is part of their application.
Usage may be in the application.
That can be quite tricky,
especially if you work centrally
or you don't own that specific application
to get that is typical.
Whereas if you do it like this
and you have it in the CUR,
you've already got access
to all of that information.
So with that, tag your usage.
You don't always have to tag everything
in your organization,
but there are some situations like this
where the nuance needs to be added
so you can get more detailed information
for your applications.
Also, try getting different metadata
or data for your unit cost.
Even things like API
usage, Lambda like we said,
or there's so many other parts
that you can grab data from CloudWatch
that you can drop in and use
as a data set to combine.
With that, I'll hand over
to Andy for our last query.
- [Andy Brown] Thanks
Steph. So who loves data?
I am 100% one of them.
There is a time and a
place for a dashboard.
But I am most happiest when I
can dive into those numbers,
dig and find and find
those optimization savings.
And I think there's
plenty of people like us,
like our application teams.
On AWS, there's a few different ways
you can share cost data.
Within the console for
cost explore and budgets,
you can use billing views,
which is a way to group accounts together
and then share that group of information
so they can go to one place.
In the world of dashboards,
Amazon QuickSight has native
support for very level security
and our cloud intelligence dashboards
has it part of our solution.
However, what about the CUR?
What happen if you want to give the CUR
to your application team,
but you don't want to
show everything to them.
And that's what we're
gonna be covering today.
We're gonna be starting off
with AWS's recommended way
for deploying the CUR
and this is what we've been using today.
We're gonna be using Athena like normal.
We're not gonna be
introducing anything else.
The only thing we're gonna
be changing for the security,
is we're gonna introduce a
new service into the mix.
And this service is AWS Lake Formation.
Lake Formation is a way for
you to create a data lake
with fine grain security controls.
So you can say app team,
you can only see this.
There's gonna be four steps
we're gonna be following for this.
First, in Lake Formation,
we need to tell it,
we need help managing securities
and this is where the
data for this is stored.
And so in the CUR world
we'll give it the S3 bucket.
We then need to create a groups,
so a group of accounts or
groups of certain resources
and that's what they call a data filter.
We're gonna be then reviewing
our Athena configuration
to make sure that our
app team can go ahead
and actually run the queries.
And then finally everything in AWS
is all about permissions and security.
So we should be going through that
and making sure they can do everything.
So with that, let's switch
over to the console.
So what we have here,
lemme go up to my query here.
I have a very simple
query just to show you
what we have in our CUR table today.
So filtering by line item
from an account name.
And this should return eight accounts,
we have currently in our AWS organization.
What I want to do today is,
I want to give access to my app team,
to their dev and prod account,
but they don't want them
to see anything else.
In this whole world,
we're using the new multi-session feature.
And so this tab over here is my app team.
So I'm still in my FinOps account
but I'm now in my app team role,
wherever think before today
or before this session,
we've been using admin.
Here, you'll see they don't
have any access to Athena,
they're getting arrows,
they can't see any tables
and there's nothing you can run.
Let's go back to our admin
and we'll come back to them later.
So like I mentioned, step
one is telling Lake Formation
I need help managing access
to accessory buckets.
So let me go to Lake Formation
and this is what Lake Formation looks like
when you first start.
By default, Lake Formation will
take in all the information
already stored within the
AWS Glue Data Catalog.
So everything you already
created in Athena for example,
so your CUR tables, any views,
all that information will still be
already available for
you in Lake Formation.
Down on the left hand side,
I need to go to my data lake locations
and I'm gonna register a new location.
I need to give it the S3 bucket name.
So let me browse, I know it's in CID,
it's my data exports.
We use one bucket for everything,
so I'm gonna select that.
We then need to provide an IAM role.
This IAM role is gonna
be then working on behalf
of the app team to
actually go ahead the data.
So this IAM role needs
access to everything.
AWS does have a service
role for you to use this
and that's what we're
gonna be using today.
However, maybe you should speak
to your securities teams first
to see if something you want,
something a little bit more restrictive.
And then the last choice you have here
is for permission mode.
You have a choice between
hybrid access mode
or Lake Formation.
Lake Formation basically
will say that all access
to this S3 bucket
is now be only maintained
in Lake Formation.
So any permissions
already granted elsewhere
through IAM for example,
will then be ignored.
In our world we're gonna be
using hybrid access mode.
Hybrid access mode is gonna
be take the permissions
with defining Lake Formation
but also use the permissions in IAM
so they work together in a hybrid way.
We're good at naming sometimes.
We're doing this
because we already have
the cost intelligence,
cloud intelligence dashboard set up.
We have our finance
teams using the CUR today
and we don't wanna break anything
but maybe in the future
we want to move to Lake Formation mode,
so we only access
permissions in one place.
So step one's done, we
told Lake Formation,
help me manage access to this S3 bucket.
Now if I go to the data missions tab,
we'll see what's already been set up.
Like I said, this already taken
everything we've got in Athena.
So if they filter by table equals CUR two,
you'll see that our admin role,
the one we've been using all today,
has access to the table
and it has access to all the columns in.
And then this is RO represents
like the IAM permissions.
So I now need to create a new
permission from my app team
and define what that means.
I do this by going to data
filters up here on the left,
I'm gonna create a new data filter.
I give it a name.
I'm gonna choose okay what
access they're gonna have.
I'm gonna have access to my data export
and then my CUR two table.
And you can restrict both
column and row level.
In my case for my app team,
I want them to only access
the unblended costs.
They don't need to see any
of the other cost columns
that might confuse them
or they might make some wrong decisions.
So I'm gonna do exclude columns,
I'm gonna filter for the cost,
I'm gonna select them all.
They can have access to cost category
and like I said, they can
have access to unblended cost
but everything else they'll get excluded.
And then to restrict that,
they can only see their
account information,
we're gonna do the very level access
and we're gonna filter those.
And what you need to do here,
is you need to complete
this statement here.
So let's star from CUR two where.
And so in our situation,
we can do line item usage
account name is like app,
'cause we have that
consistent naming convention.
You can put anything in it,
if you want it filter
by particular products
or particular resource
IDs, you can put that.
It's just a normal where statement
you were writing in Athena.
One thing you can't easily
do is filter by tag.
And this is due to the way
that CUR two works with tags.
With CUR two,
tags are now stored in a map
function called resource tags.
And so Athena and Glue can't
see the values of the tag
and so this will fail when
you try and validate it,
there is a workaround.
What you can do in Athena is create a view
where you take the relevant tags
into its own separate column
and you do everything
we're showing you today
based on that view, not the table.
And so that's the workaround,
but for us we want to
do it by account name
and so this should be sufficient for us.
So create the data filter.
So what I've done is I created the filter,
but I haven't said who should
have access to the filter.
So lemme tick the box,
I'm gonna do grant permissions
and I'm gonna choose the
IAM role for my app team.
You choose what I already
picked up all the things,
'cause I did from the data permissions tab
and you choose what access you want.
So I'm gonna allow them
to select and describe.
I'm not allowing them to drop,
I'm not gonna allow them
grant any more permissions.
Just select and be able to run it.
And then you've got this last tick box
in our case we're gonna tick it.
Basically this tick box says,
do you want to enable this right now?
And so you might not,
maybe there's lots of
other configurations.
Maybe there's other data source
or other teams you want to do
and you're not ready for them to go live.
This is the only thing we're doing.
So we're ready to go live.
So we're gonna tick it.
If you don't tick this box,
you can just go to the hybrid
access here on the left
and then just go ahead and
you've set it up there.
But our case, we're ready to go.
So that's the Lake Formation done.
Step one and two.
Step three is all about Athena.
For those who set up Athena before,
you know you need to provide
Athena with an S3 bucket.
If you give your app team
access to this S3 bucket
for the Athena results,
they might actually see
other people's results.
And so get access to data don't want.
And if they're anyone like me,
I'm sneaky, I'm very
good at digging around
and trying to get access to
data in slightly different ways.
And so this is not great.
We want to try and avoid this situation.
And so what we're gonna do in Athena is,
we're gonna create a new
workgroup just for this app team
and workgroup thing about
is just a new configuration setting.
So let me go back to Athena.
I'm gonna open up the menu
here and go to workgroups.
I'm gonna create my
workgroup, give it a name.
I'm gonna leave everything the same here.
And then it's when we go to
crew result conversation.
In the past you'd have the customer manage
and you'll provide the S3
bucket, you might create it.
In our case, we're gonna
be using a new feature
called Athena Managed Storage.
Here Athena's gonna manage
the S3 bucket for you.
No one in your account is
gonna have access to this.
This is also available free of charge,
so when things are free and age of risk,
take advantage of it.
But it's free of charge
and it'll keep the data for 24 hours.
And so perfect for this situation,
'cause it means no one can go
and see other people's results.
So I'm gonna create my workgroup.
We're now on the final stage.
The final stage is setting
up the IAM permissions
and I'm gonna go to IAM
identity and access manager.
I need to go to my app team role.
And you'll see I already
have one policy for them.
This app team,
I've already actually given
access to the billing view.
So they're being used to seeing
a group of accounts within Cost Explorer.
And this is where they got
like that appetite to see more
and they wanted access to the CUR.
And so I need to grant new
additional access for them.
I've actually already
written a policy for this,
mainly because policies as you know,
always can be quite difficult
because you need to try and
work out what's going on
and make sure you get the right thing.
So I created one for you.
As a reminder, everything
we're showing you today
is available in our GitHub
including this policy.
So you'll be able to take
it from there and reuse it.
So lemme sort for my CUR. Here we go.
But let me take you through
what's in this policy.
First, this section is
the most important one.
This is the thing which
gives the access team
access to the information
in Lake Formation.
So this will allow them to go
and pick up that permission
we signed for them.
Everything else within the
policy is our standard setup.
So we have all the normal Athena things,
they can run queries, get results,
but you can see I defined the workgroup
to be that one we created up.
So they can only run
things in that workgroup
and access that configuration.
We then give them Glue data access,
so they can see the table.
But once again, I only give them access
to that CUR two table so
they can't see anything else.
So let me go ahead, let me tick the box,
let me add the permissions
and we are ready to go.
And this is where,
this is where I'm gonna get some marks.
Let's see what I have messed up.
So I'm gonna go back to Athena.
First we're gonna check is,
I haven't messed up my own access
and I haven't taken anything away.
So let me rerun this query here.
You can run it.
And you see we're still
getting eight accounts.
So good. My access is still
stable, things are working.
Now let me go to this tab here.
Oh no.
- Oh no, Andy gets an error.
(Steph laughs)
- [Andy Brown] Do you mind?
We should need Steph to lock me back in.
- Let me, I've swap over.
- Okay.
- You can keep talking.
- Yeah.
So we're gonna be going back here
and fingers crossed, once
Steph's logged us back in,
we will be able to see
that they now have
access to the CUR table.
- [Steph Gooch] All
right, let's have a look.
- [Andy Brown] This is what happens
when you prepare too early for a talk.
So here you go. I know.
- [Steph Gooch] Oh, interesting.
You need to go to the reinventing.
- [Andy Brown] Yeah, maybe go, yeah.
- [Steph Gooch] Let's see.
- [Andy Brown] But that's like, okay,
once Steph's got this back up and running,
we'll show you exactly
and fingers crossed it is working.
And what will happen is
within the FinOps account,
this app team will only
see their two accounts
and so they can now run queries.
And so what we really want
you to take away from this is,
everything we've shown
you with Lake Formation
is not actually CUR specific.
It could be anything
you've done in Athena.
We yes, ta-da.
Okay, so here we go. So
we're in a FinOps account.
I'm in my app team role.
I don't think that's, you can-
- Just come.
- Yeah, okay. Yeah.
So you can see here on my left hand side,
my app team can now see the CUR two role.
So if I expand it out and I
filter for those cost columns,
yes, they can only see those cost columns,
they give them access to,
they can't see anything else.
And now if I go back,
let me see what we've got here.
Oh no, which one? Here we go. Okay.
Okay, I'm gonna take
the query we had before.
I'm gonna paste it in here
and now this is the one with
the matter, fingers crossed.
Let's see if it works.
It should now return back
only the two accounts.
So again, so they have access.
So they, like I said, they
now have access to run queries
and do feel themselves,
but only see their data.
Everything I've shown you
today is not CUR specific.
So think about what other
teams are reaching out to you
and asking for data.
Maybe you could repeat the same process.
Long as you can get the data into S3,
you can get to Athena
you can get to Athena,
then you can register it in Lake Formation
and manage your order.
So think about maybe you're
downloading cost optimization,
hub data exports,
maybe some inventory or other
like reports you're producing
and you can this solution for that.
And so today we covered three main topics.
We started off with looking at
how to optimize data transfer
by introducing VPC Flow Logs
and using that as an
additional data source.
We then talked about AI
and work out how do you know
if your AI workload is efficient.
And then finally we talked
about how can we share this data
with more people about
sharing in a secure way.
I'm gonna hand it over to
Steph to finish us off.
- [Steph Gooch] We've made
it to our call to actions.
A couple of things for
you guys to take away.
Discover other data sources.
We showed you VPC Flow Logs,
but there are CloudWatch, S3,
there's loads of other services
that you can plug into Athena
and start to connect this data.
Tag your usage.
Like we said, we're relevant.
I always advise an account kind
of organizational structure,
but if there's specific
use cases for tagging,
do enforce those.
Enable RLS, give other
people the power of the CUR,
give them the chance to go in
and dive into this data as well.
Now I know that that is a lot of stuff
that we have covered today,
but I want you to have a go.
I want you to pick one
thing from today's session
and have a go in your
accounts, that is it.
Can get back after re:Invent.
See if it works for you.
Here's the QR code you've
all been waiting for
with the GitHub repo in it.
It's a link tree.
There's a bunch of
different resources in here,
including a home
recording of this session.
This one is recorded and
we'll come out later,
but we have a home recording in here
that you can just pop
in and see the queries.
There's also our LinkedIn,
so you can see whatever
fourth that I have to do.
- [Andy Brown] We've got another session.
We do have another session.
- [Steph Gooch] We're
gonna add them together.
- Yeah.
- And then we will also have
some resources like
inference profiles in there.
And with that,
thank you so much for joining us today.
I can't wait to see what you do
for the cost and usage report.
Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
(audience applauding)